[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
now
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
no check this out
[Music]
this
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
go check this out
[Music]
so
[Music]
good
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
from
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
one hello everyone and welcome to
gamespot's
pre-show and post show for sony's latest
playstation 5 event it's going to be a
big one today so
joining me to help round up all the news
to more hussein
playstation cinco and michael hyam
playstation tatlow oh very good
uh playstation oh that's three damn
i got my numbers long wanted in german
very
exciting day today it's gonna be a big
one uh microsoft have pretty much laid
all their cards on the table when it
comes to the xbox series x and series
s you know it doesn't matter how many
times i say it it doesn't
get easier you've really got to put the
enunciation in there
we know pricing we know release date
sony we know launch lineup sony we've
got
what's in the box that's it we know you
know the two the two different
types of consoles so i think do we want
to play price j
price betting like the price is right
straight off the bat
let's do it okay michael i'm gonna come
to you first
how much do you think both versions of
the ps5 are going to cost so we got the
disc
version and the different version i'm
gonna
aim high with pricing here i know it's
it's a it's a hot take
um but uh you know i think that
what makes me think that the the ps5
disc version was probably going to go
for
i'm going to say 550 i wouldn't want to
say 600 but i think that is asking a
little too much
um i do believe that microsoft is
thinking about
when they price their thing like okay we
need to undercut in the market
like straight up so i think that was
their mentality to begin with i don't
think
i don't necessarily think sony has to
worry about that which is why i'm
leaning towards something like 550 uh
for
the disc version and maybe the diskless
version would be 500
so that that's kind of where i'm
thinking uh uh so i'm uh
i think i got the price right i don't
know
the price is right time what about you
i'm gonna i'm gonna think optimistically
in terms of how
sony is approaching this i think what
they're gonna want to do i
imagine what they want to do is keep the
train rolling and i hope that the
discussions that they've had have been
right
we might need to take a hit on this if
we're going to continue the momentum
that we built up with the playstation 4.
we might take that hit but in doing a a
attractive price that kind of like um
makes a you know we lose a bit of money
on we can potentially in the long run
maintain a position of
strength and continue to um benefit that
so i think i'm gonna go
500 for the um disc
uh drive one and then 450
for the diskless one um i realized that
it's a bit optimistic but that's what
i'm going for
like in 2020 we need all the optimism we
can i honestly i agree with you i think
disk 3 will be around 450 i think
disc will be 500 i don't think they will
ever
ever do the 600 again not after what
happened with the ps3 launch
the thing that concerns me a little bit
is
microsoft have basically they stumbled
when the xbox one launched
they have spent the entire generation
coming up with a subscription service
with game pass game plus ultimate
which is the best deal in gaming we say
it every single time
i mean if sony is gonna price on the
lower side is ps plus it obviously makes
them a ton of money but is it enough
you know like if microsoft can price
very aggressively because they make so
much in subscriptions
is sony in the same boat we're not gonna
know we're gonna find out
today i'm very excited but there's other
stuff taken into consideration as well
launch date so microsoft
confirmed after those leaks november
10th do we think sony's gonna go ahead
or after that
tam you first this time i'm gonna
continue with the
uh sony coming out just ready to throw
hands in all directions and say like
they're gonna be
like the beginning of that week or the
week before
i i if i was there i'd be like i mean
like there's been a lot of discussions
about
shipment um availability and the method
of shipment which could complicate it
but i'm just creating this world the
world's craziest scenario here and say
that they're gonna
not only undercut not only give them a
runner attractive price but come in a
week earlier
just to be like ah we're here first
michael are you i think um i think the
ps5 will probably launch in the same
week uh i would say maybe the 13th but i
know that tuesday is always kind of like
that
that um that aim that every almost
everything has
to uh release within a week but i think
they might do the same day uh
i i would suspect that i don't think
they want to show up a little
late i don't uh but i do i would lean
towards what tam was saying about being
they're either
the same week or they're a couple days
earlier or the week earlier
that i don't think they can mess around
i mean
they're going to sell consoles
regardless but in terms of getting in
front of the competition i do think that
that's
i would bet on that um but uh
one other thing yeah like like i
mentioned that i think they're going to
sell consoles regardless
uh people are going to be out buying
ps5s i think
uh so and with that in mind uh that's
kind of also going back to the price
thing is that
uh they can get away with juicing up the
price a little bit
but they can also get away with maybe
launching a couple days afterwards so
basically what i'm saying is that i have
no idea uh
and i'm waiting for this reveal stream
to answer all those questions but
you can i think you can justify it
either way but
we probably won't have to contemplate or
justify those thoughts
any longer after the stream so that's
actually what i'm looking forward to
you mean you're looking forward to the
discourse stopping about pricing
yes like
we have a show at gamespot just about
you know next-gen consoles and
every single week it's been like we
still don't know how much this
console is gonna cost but i'm very glad
to finally get some clarity
um okay i think we've talked sharp
when it comes to pricing and release
dates i think we've covered that enough
let's talk about games
because i'm looking at the notes of the
show here jim ryan says
there they have plenty of games still in
development some big reveals i don't
know if we're going to be getting those
today i assume we're going to be getting
updates on a launch lineup um let's
go in with i think the game that
everyone assumes is going to be their
launch title their big grand launch
title and that's spider-man
miles morales um tam i'll come to you
first because you are
you're the comic book guy amongst all of
us uh are you excited for
my miles morales what do you want to see
from it today
yeah i think thus far they haven't like
given us a definitive
release date for it so i would hope that
they have i think sony's gonna try
again thinking in a best case scenario
as myself who's working at sony i
imagine sony's looking at what microsoft
have done and gone
okay they've got a really great price
what don't they have they don't have a
big launch title
and they don't have a lot of games that
make people say i need to upgrade right
now
so i think if they're smart sony will
come out and give people exactly that
so that could be a release date for
miles morales show off
a bit more about it and kind of
reiterate what's been said
um since the last time they showed it
immediately after that there was some
discussion about whether this was a true
sequel or
whether it just was a dlc and in the
time since you know they said
uh insomniac said this is a full arc for
miles morales that
started in spider-man so they're
positioning it as a
me full you know full experience if not
like a
40 30 whatever it may be 20 hour game so
i think they would want to come out and
reiterate that so i'm excited to see
that come out and then do that and show
off more of the game obviously i'm a
huge fan of spiderman as many many
people are
and that last game was fantastic um i
think the story stuff that it did in
in the first game was interesting but i
feel like insomniac has more space to do
something unique
with miles um not many stories outside
of comics been told
with miles outside of um you know the
the movie
um but i think there's a good
opportunity there and
it could be a really really like heavy
punch right at the start if they
if they went with that i think as well
with all the hubbub around spider-man
um and his lack of appearance on uh
xbox when it comes to marvel's avengers
it's a big
it's a big boon for them to have
spider-man exclusively to the police
station so
i i fully anticipate we're going to be
seeing more from miles but speaking of
insomniac
michael i'm going to come to you because
uh we were talking about this before we
went live
ratchet and clank again another title
that's just
launch window whatever the hell that
means um we've seen quite a lot of it i
think out of all the ps5 games we've
seen the most out of ratchet and clank
most recently at opening night live at
gamescom do you think we're gonna get
that coveted release date today
yes i do and uh it's funny that you
mentioned that it's
the ps5 game that we've seen the most of
which kind of makes me lean towards that
being the big
game that they're going to push for
launch day uh i also
personally believe that miles morales
it's either that or miles of morales
that will come out on launch day
um of course they say holiday or launch
window
uh i think that they say that to play
the to keep their cards close to their
chest so they don't have to
you know create any more speculation on
the console's release date itself
uh so that's kind of how they can play
it safe and then
for example maybe today it's like all
right since we know the launch
of the console this is the this is the
game that
is going to come out day one or these
are the games that come out day one
uh so i really think that ratchet and
clank
is this game is the showcase for what
the ps5
is capable of of course they've stressed
the the rip the rift aspect to it you
know this game is called
subtitle rift apart and that's a big
mechanic in this game
based on what they've shown so far and
that is directly tied to the ps5
capabilities when it comes to the ssd's
load times
so it's like people i think there's a
lot of adoration for ratchet and clank
itself
as it ties to the sony playstation brand
um
but it's also a showcase of what the ps5
is capable of
and it just looks like a ton of fun
ratchet and clank games are always a ton
of fun
uh they're approachable uh they're
bombastic they're fun to look at this
game
looks so good and it looks so much fun
so i think this is like
ratchet clang griffith part would be the
perfect launch game for
the ps5 though i do think that miles
morales will
give you that that sort of edgier
edgier game if you if you're looking for
that with the ps5 but
i would mostly bet on ratchet clank
being a launch launch title with ps5
i think yeah i think i agree i think
that would be really smart so i need to
come out of the gate with both of those
as launch titles um so let's move on
to we know this one is coming
but whether it's a launch title or not
and tam this is for you
do you think it's gonna be demon souls
think yes
like yeah you think it's gonna be a
launch title
yes i do i think it
non-stop all the time and non-stop
thinking about it being alone it's like
will it be uh maybe i like i mean
like we talked about this before when it
was announced like that game's
development has been rumored for a
significant period of time
which if you're someone like me that
wants to think that it's a launch title
that gives you kind of an indication
that it's been in development i should
be pretty far along if not
reaching like the end of its cycle
maybe that's um wishful thinking i mean
it is wishful thinking
literally um but i'm i'm optimistic i
feel like
diversity in the launch title is what um
what uh sony is gonna go for i think
again
taking that scenario where i'm mr or
sony and i'm trying to
punch hard and punch quickly um
catering to as many different uh styles
of gameplay or like
taste of gameplay is is the idea right
like spider-man
hits the mainstream ratchet and clank is
the people who know and love playstation
and also
is for you know um people who are
younger and
and more attracted to that kind of pixar
style game
looking game demon souls comes in for
the like hardcore
people who are now have developed around
the souls genre and
understand some of the lineage of it and
we'll be excited for that
and then there's a few other games that
are coming up that i also think could be
launch window if not launch day
michael have you ever dabbled in in
souls
in and if not it demon soul's the one
for you yeah man i'm a real gamer out
here you know i played some souls games
uh not all of them though i'm not on
tam's level
uh but obviously like bloodborne is
tam's favorite game of all time
uh i saw it in your background man
you're not you're not subtle
uh but always there but
yeah like i tam had mentioned that you
know a three-pronged approach to
launch day would be really smart that
would be really strong i mean
you know you when you think of sony
exclusives you probably like think of
things like god of war or um
or like last of us which we just had
recently
so to bring in the the cycle of of
ps5 titles with with these three games i
think that would be really strong
because like you said like tam said
it caters to different audiences and
these aren't just like
like these aren't multi-platform games
these are these are
big deals so uh and you know i i
i am excited for the xbox series x or
the xbox series platform
um but again i think that the the thing
that ps5 has up their sleeves
is excitement for games
themselves and these three alone i mean
they might not have the widest appeal or
i mean
miles morales is going to have mass
appeal and like i said that's going to
be the mainstream game that's going to
hit everyone across the board but
having that variety on launch window or
at least
uh or on launch day maybe if if we're if
we're feeling lucky
uh that would be that would make i think
that would make people think a little
a little bit more about maybe going to
the ps5
on launch day or launch window uh so
that would be really exciting
and i would love to see that but again
you know wishful thinking i can't
can't be out here like asking for games
that aren't ready so
uh but uh at least from the stream today
i think we're gonna see
more of those three games i think uh or
at least of miles morales and demon
souls
to see how that conversion with that new
art style with that
new fidelity for demon souls is looking
and kind of set the tone i want
like i'm excited for miles morales but i
want to i want to know what the tone is
like i want to know how big that game is
uh and i think those are those are
things that would get me excited uh to
hop on the platform early
definitely i i mean i totally agree i
think it's very smart if
demon souls is going to be coming out
this this launch window too
like you just appeal you just extend
your reach and i think the thing as well
is
like we you have so many third-party
games that we're not even discussing
today like we know
that watchdogs and assassins and
cyberpunk are all going to be coming to
both consoles
and yet it's it's exclusives that really
kind of like
dominate the conversation especially
right now so speaking of let's move on
to horizon forbidden west i almost said
zero dawn again or like
rise of the planet of the apes dawn of
the planet of the apes like
horizon rise of the west uh but
forbidden
west um i honestly don't think this is
going to be a launch title
um horizon got a lot of love it was very
popular when it came out in 2017
aloy has become something of a
playstation icon in that time
i i was playing it again recently
actually i love the combat in that game
so much
do i want to have a sequel yes i do i
don't
think judging on like this pre-rendered
stuff that we're seeing here like we
haven't seen any
year i think it's probably gameplay next
year tam
gonna come to you yeah i think horizon
yeah i think like we talked about the
uh you know the the one two or even one
two three hit punch that um
we what i uh kind of would love to see
them do with spiderman ratchet and demon
souls
i think they also need to to think about
banking games
that will continue that relay race kind
of approach to it that the
exclusives they can hand off to and i
think with those three games
and then a bunch of games that you
mentioned that we're not specifically
focusing on today the third party titles
like assassins
cyberpunk and various other games coming
from
playstation partners you kind of feel
that gap in between which gives
this game horizon forbidden west some
time to kind of continue
um gesticulating and being created and
you know
being refined up until the kind of
momentum starts to dip slightly and then
it can come in and pick it up back again
and start running forward like this is a
good game to tell everybody is coming to
keep them excited
and then give to them after the initials
uh crop of
launch games are kind of done and people
are starting to forget about them and
are looking for a new reason um to to
continue buying games
and i mean speaking of launch titles
actually uh
cana kana i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly was actually delayed very very
recently
very cute looking game like really
really charming art style i definitely
wanted to see more about it
michael do you think that's a good move
it's obviously a good move for them
because they get to um
you know spend more time and get the
game in the position that they wanted to
be in but in terms of sony's launch
lineup
is that leaving a hole or do you think
there's plenty else that people can be
getting on with
uh i think it's fine i i i'm personally
excited for
kenna like that's um i'm interested in
to see like how it builds this brand new
world who this
uh character is uh and that the the
little little what are the
little uh those little smoky things that
follow around oh they're so cute
oh my gosh look at their big old
eyeballs
this game is so it looks it's very
charming all right
it seems very charming but you know i'm
willing to wait for it i think that
it's not necessary for this game this
style of game
uh that's brand new like this is a new
ip
for it to come out the gate on launch
window i think
you know it it may even benefit from
you know waiting until there's a there's
an established
install base for the ps5 and then
you have a bunch of people with the
console and then boom you come out with
this
this new game that no one's ever seen
before a brand new ip
and i think that you know it i i don't
think it would be a system seller so i
don't think it's necessary for it to
be around launch window but again like i
said it could
probably benefit from you know taking
its time
and also being there when there's a
bunch of people
using ps5s uh but yeah this is i i love
games like this where it's not like that
bombastic
aaa style thing that's going to blow you
away with the highest realistic fidelity
i'm
i'm interested in what you do with art
styles how you communicate that in the
world whether it's through
the storytelling the narrative music or
just visual cues within the world
getting creative
with how games look and how that turns
into gameplay functions
uh so this looks like like a third
person action venture game so there's
probably a lot of puzzles
some i'm expecting some some clever
combat systems
uh so yeah i'm interested in those
things i don't necessarily need
that super hyper realistic uh style of
game even if i'm going into a next
generation console i want to see
some creativity some new ips that's uh
that that from that perspective i'm
hyped about this one
me too so we've got about 10 minutes
left until the
playstation 5 uh event make sure to stay
here right on youtube.com slash games
but afterwards going to be dissecting
all the biggest news stories
so let's quickly rattle through some
other games that we're hoping to see
more of
today so personally that's why tokyo
i'm like i know that death loop's been
delayed i've made my peace with it i'm
fine
i don't anticipate seeing any death loop
today i honestly think there will be
some kind of other event
maybe in january or february to be like
and here's the slate for the rest of the
year
however ghost wire tokyo i think is
i think i'm primed to see more of that
game today tam what do you reckon
yeah i i think the i mean bethesda
probably wants to have
something right and of all the games
that that they have
on their slate like this is the most
exciting that they can show off we're
not seeing
starfield we're not seeing the next
elder scrolls for a long time
so and this this is in good shape and
they don't really have to show
too much of it off it doesn't have to be
a lengthy kind of you know a gameplay
um demo because the time doesn't really
permit that kind of thing but i think
this is an easy one for them to show off
and
it always looks good when you see and
also like
the less you explain the more exciting
it is it's one of those situations where
it's a rare game where you don't have to
say anything and that kind of helps its
marketing in a lot of ways so they can
show off some weird stuff happening in
this game
a bunch of weird yokai and some strange
environments and
just remind everyone it's from shinji
mokami and tango and and everyone will
be like yep that's that's
i'm up for that yes please
sign me up yeah i really i i'm very
excited about this one i
i just think it looks so unusual i'm
ready to be scared again
um speaking of just while we're on this
train of thought let's talk about
resident
evil village so please don't call it
resident evil 8
according to capcom but village so we
know we're going to get more of an
extended look at the game at tokyo game
show
which is at the end of the month so i
think if they said september 27th
um they will have more news we were
supposed to have village news last month
um didn't end up happening however
i feel like in my heart of hearts
i want village news today but i also
want the confirmation that four
is getting remade that's what i want and
i know that you
this is the energy i'm putting out in
the world i'm manifesting
remake michael i'm gonna come to you do
you think today is gonna be the day to
see more from village
yeah i think so uh i don't necessarily
think all right we shouldn't expect it
to be
around launch window or even this year
uh just based on how little we've seen
so far
uh but i think it would be smart to show
off what
this game is but i do feel like
you know we're going back to it it seems
like we're going back to first person
resident evil right
um yeah uh that that much is clear
uh but it's also another case of where i
the less i know the more i'm enticed by
it because like when i played resident
evil 7 i'm like
oh it's first person also i don't want
to know anything else about this game
i just want to be able to experience it
clean um i do think that
you know fans such as us are going to
want
a little bit more hint in terms of its
story connections across the
the broader uh resident evil lore uh i
i think if i if i recall correctly this
is connected to
resident evil 7 um
yeah yeah so uh
but you know give us a little bit more
in terms of how
how those things are connected and then
that's it all right um
i mean i'm sure they're gonna show more
later on
as we get closer to his release date but
this is this is really exciting i
really like what what what capcom did
with doing first person resident evil
it felt so different yet it still
captured the spirit of it and if they
can do that again
i'm all for it like let let's go uh but
yeah i think a horror or a horror style
game
somewhere around launch whether it's uh
whether it's um
uh ghost wire tokyo or if it's resident
evil village like
i think that would also add to the
variety of its uh
playstation 5's uh portfolio and uh yeah
i we will probably see more of that
today
all right we've got about five minutes
left until sony kicks off
their event so let's quickly run through
the rumor mill
michael i'm going to come back to you
for this one final fantasy 16.
i think it's time
i don't know i don't know if it's time
but
i want to see it i want to see what
final fantasy 16 is
yo okay
like they could announce it today and it
could be seven years away
that's another thing too is because
square enix i know y'all love to do this
i know y'all love showing off games
before the way before they're even ready
uh and if you if you want to keep it up
sure like hey let's go i'm fine with
that if you're gonna say like oh final
fantasy 16 in
2024 you know what at least at least it
got something
that that would be wild because there's
obviously rumors and then
people are sharing that screenshot of
the airship uh up in the sky
from i guess uh some leak or whatever
and that looks a lot like the
the airship in final fantasy 6 so it's
like okay is final hazy going back to
that that old school style
of fantasy world with 16
is that even what this what this leaked
screenshot even is
but if it is it could be it could be
like a title card it could be metroid
prime 4 style
and i'll be hyped uh if there's more
than that oh i'm about to get real
emotional boy
oh tom you're shaking your head
you don't think it's not i agree with i
agree with what i am saying but also the
x factor in all this is they still have
a final fantasy 7
two parts of that to make and not get in
the way of
like i yeah i i i
wonder i mean like square enix has made
some
some decisions in the past that are
perhaps a bit confusing but like
i think among them i don't know how
smart i think it is to have three final
fantasy
games actively in in rotation and
and promotion between the mmo final
fantasy 7
remake part two and whatever this new
final fantasy may be
however like heim said and like lucy
said like um
that doesn't stop them from going yeah
we're making final fantasy 16 here's
some amano artwork and see you in
10 years look
you just oh god i
you know honestly i just wouldn't put it
past them we waited five years
for seven remake part one i i'm ready to
be hurt again
i'm ready to be kept on the hook so if
16 does get announced today
i'm very ready for it uh tam this is one
well i've got two for tam
one is three five six and the other one
is bloodborne
five we've got about three minutes
before the show so i'm going to i'm
coming here
gotta go fast uh three five six
maybe not that likely there was some
sketchy rumors and some insiders
or like some people saying that the
origin originally it was supposed to be
announced already it had a team-based
dynamic but wasn't received that well
internally and there was some uh kind of
infighting about
pro who's managing projects and that
kind of stuff and it hasn't materialized
and then in the meantime
a season a new season pass for 355
showed up which is like
that was unexpected so a lot of people
are saying
um again huge grain of salt like an
actual cow salt lick sized one
um that this is to buy time for them to
rework street fighter six
um while they do that and obviously
since the um
yoshinori owner director forum five has
left the company which is
surprising after two decades so is it
likely
not right now is it gonna show up
eventually i'd say so
uh bloodborne another one that's a big
rumor and
the the rumors come from two very like
out of nowhere places it was like a pc
gaming inquisition a youtube channel and
a streamer
um but they both said similar things um
and the uh
discussion is like um it's a improved
textures 4k
improved loading times and is for pc and
is developed by q lock and
they are the company that the polish
developer that did um
dark souls remastered um and also
uh blue point is in uh involved in that
in some capacity
is that likely again i want to believe
um and i and and i hope that it will um
but also uh elden ring where are you man
i was gonna say i mean which from game
are we meant to be getting hyped for at
the minute i mean
i've got capacity to be capacity behind
all of them but
i i would love to see demon souls i
would love to see bloodborne on ps5
um we've got about a minute or so left
before we go over to sony
um my rumor that i hope to god is true
and at this point
it pretty much has to be because of the
box art league mass effect trilogy
so i i mean there is a mini direct
tomorrow
there is the ps5 event today i
assume it's got to be at one of those
i've waited so long i mean i say i've
waited so long i could play it
right now i could play it on pc i could
play on xbox however
if the if they're bringing it to nextgen
if they're making changes to it if
they're making little tweaks to make it
better graphical improvements
i am so ready for all of this i am
ready to play through that trilogy again
like this
this autumn winter is gonna ruin my
repetitive strain injury because i'm
just gonna be playing
so much and yet i'll be playing a
trilogy that's you know 10 years old at
this point but you know i'm so ready for
it
okay so those are the rumors
as always i love to do wild card
predictions just before we go over
tam oh elven ring
okay we're going right now it's
happening ps5
each time i awake this planet seems
somehow
different
this is the power that flows through
this land
yet you do not fully understand it
but whatever comes i will be ready
okay let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
you all know the target shiva's dominant
and only the dominant how do we even
know the girl will be among them
our kind do not question orders we
follow them
sergeant let's summon their icon
i can't i think's a bloody mountain
our foe will not relinquish their mother
crystal easily
this will be a bitter fight
you should not be out of doors we have
discussed this
come joshua your father will be
expecting us
[Music]
i am joshua's shield
[Music]
i'm sworn to protect you
what do you mean you refuse did you not
pledge your sword to our cause
what does it matter it was the dull
necks who drove back the crusaders in
the battle of the twin realms
without the blessing of the mother
crystal we cannot defend our realm from
the spread of the blight
imperial vipers do they really mean to
invade us
it's the archduke's son
the felix
but that's impossible
the legacy of the crystals
has shaped our history
for long enough
i'll kill you
if it's the last thing i do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's too cold to change out here
dang i'm late for mom's rally
[Music]
subway card check you got the house key
yeah i got it
come on we're going to be late
hey dude i am so filling your suit with
snow
are you still wearing your suit yeah you
know just in case
it's gonna be fine
see this is my favorite part of living
in harlem
pop-up street fair best food in the city
awesome music
man this would be great for the last
beat i was working on
i should get back into mixing yeah it's
been a while
what do you think about rio morales are
you going to vote for her
it's still hard to think of mom as a
politician she's been a teacher my whole
life
similar skill sets right growling people
educating them
making sure they don't throw things at
each other
hi i'm brian horton creative director at
insomniac games
we're excited to show you this first
look at gameplay from marvel spider-man
miles morales
our story picks up one year after the
events of the first game
and we find miles new home harlem is in
danger
trouble bruised while miles mom rio
morales leads an election rally
a war between the devious energy
corporation roxanne and the underground
a high-tech criminal army led by the
tinkerer starts to break out
in this gameplay sequence captured on
playstation 5 hardware
the underground attacks roxanne sending
the rally into chaos
in a fight that spills onto the
braithwaite ridge where the underground
tries to steal roxanne's experimental
energy source
new form let's take a look
let's not shoot each other all right
we're after the new form ignore
everything else
get rid of him then grab as much as you
can carry
[Music]
keep him busy
i have to stop this
people are trapped over there i have to
push past these guys
[Music]
where is he
[Music]
oh
[Music]
no
[Music]
the bus
everybody get out
thank you man those people
they're trapped
i've got an
i idea something they can cross
i can stop this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
magic both beautiful and powerful
binds together our long history
that common bond we share is the legacy
of hogwarts
[Music]
now it is time to add your own story to
these hallowed walls
and quite possibly shape the future
of the wizarding world
every corridor every portrait
every stone in this castle tells the
story
witches and wizards who came before
here you will meet lifelong friends and
grow into your own
magical abilities in the classrooms of
the world's most
talented professors and
while your journey begins it holds
brewing potions
taming fantastic beasts
and mastery spells
[Music]
there is a larger world beyond these
walls
a world filled with dangers you can't
yet
imagine an ancient knowledge
long gone from this world
that strange and mysterious talent you
possess
may be the key to unlocking this
dormant power
your potential
is limitless
[Music]
but what form will it take
the journey ahead will reveal
what you stand for
the choices you make now
will define the legacy of hogwarts
[Music]
hi everyone i'm dan vondrag creative
director at raven
one of our goals as developers is to
bring the game world to life unlike
anything you've ever experienced and the
playstation 5 is making that happen
with the power of the new console we've
been able to significantly enhance the
overall experience
from what you see in the world how it
feels in your hands to what you hear
around you
in black ops cold war you will be
transported to the year 1981
in the middle of one of the most
dangerous times the world has ever known
the height of the cold war the following
is a portion of the first campaign
mission
where you've been given the name of a
high value target linked to the iran
hostage crisis
but in true black ops style nothing is
as it seems
take a look
the team arrived in turkey a few hours
ago they should be in position shortly
airfield's just up ahead let's go find
this [ __ ]
priority is to ideal raj things go hot
[Music]
so
check it out
[Music]
incoming truck left side
mirage might be in the truck
everyone in a truck that's gotta be a
rash
hold fire we need a positive id
that's our man take him out
[Music]
yeah we missed him away
get it
[Music]
we're not done
[Music]
so
it's one part of the plan let's go
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed that sneak peek at
the campaign for black ops cold war
there are many more twists and turns
along the way as you begin to unravel
the truth and we can't wait for you to
play it soon
in addition to the story campaign cold
war features the next generation of
multiplayer online combat
and an all new awesome zombies
experience today i have the special
honor to announce on behalf of my
friends at treyarch
that the playstation community doesn't
have to wait to play multiplayer
starting this friday playstation players
will be able to play the multiplayer
alpha exclusively
on playstation 4. and for those of you
that are watching at home on your ps4
you can pre-load the experience starting
tomorrow we can't wait to see you online
friday and through the weekend
enjoy the rest of the show
[Music]
all
chris what the hell
take him away
in life and in death we give glory
the bell tolls for us all they're coming
[Laughter]
again
quit being so paranoid
long ago a young girl went with her
mother to pick berries for her father
who was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark
cold silence the bush is empty
yet determined to find the berries the
rascal broke free of mother's grasp
and vanished into the trees
[Music]
mothers worried cries faded fast as the
girl ran on
over vine under branch
and into the forest
it's just a local tale
[Music]
if it's just looking window shop away
[Music]
you want out of a time loop you gotta
learn how it works
black reef is a puzzle and each
visionary is a
different piece
here's eagle i am a respected scientist
i've done so many loops i've learned to
run circles around him
hey over here i'm coming for you
i've tried taking my targets out one by
one
more than i can remember but there is
never enough time
i go after one another lives because
right now half an island away a
different visionary is throwing his
nightly cannibal masquerade
alexis dorsey everybody shut up
this is my jam igor is a big fan
yet somehow he never makes it to the
party
something keeps him home gold you're
there
buddy here's the invite to the party
and here's why igor blew it off he made
some kind of scientific breakthrough
that morning
i did it i did it it works that he makes
everyone
unless i get there first
[Applause]
[Music]
no experiment no breakthrough
no reason for igor not to drink his
disappointment with alexis
now i got a shot at killing them both at
the same time
in the same loop
oh i'm talking about you baby
[Music]
a little house here
eight targets on my list every one of
them with grand
plans for eternal life to break the loop
i gotta break the rules clocks ticking
and you just ran out of time you keep
forgetting cult
i'm not like those other idiots
only got one name on my list yours
[Music]
[Music]
that day if our positions were switched
would our fates be different
would i have your life and your mind
you a demon
[Music]
um
real before me
[Music]
this is
[Music]
rest in peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
devil may cry
[Music]
[Music]
what are they doing did those fugitive
morons burn down their own hideout
it sounds idiotic but
that's exactly what it looks like
bad woman for burning down my farm
hi i'm lorne lanning creative director
of odd world soul storm
and we're excited to bring you an
all-new exclusive trailer from the game
here our unlikely hero abe finds himself
fresh off the back of freeing his people
from the nefarious rupture farms he
thinks the journey is over
but soon discovers it has only just
begun
the stakes are higher the threats are
larger the obstacles are more devious
and it's all made possible by the power
of playstation 5.
enjoy
[Music]
we are not letting that guy get away
from us
[Music]
again
[Music]
wait here hey why not hold up i could go
for a sandwich right now we got to get
out of here come on
let's get out of here my tummy's
growling
[Music]
gregory your friends are worried about
you
they're here with me please come out
gregory i may have lost my tempo earlier
but it was just a quench it won't happen
again
it's been such a difficult day for all
of us
why don't you come out and we can play a
game together
it won't happen again
gregory be still
i think she's found us
[Music]
[Music]
soul of the lost withdrawn from its
vessels
that strength be granted so the world
might be mended
soul of the lost withdrawn from its
vessel
let strength be granted so the world
might be mended
so the world might be mended
oh
oh
[Music]
i shall await thy return with a slayer
of demons
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
future
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you kill something that big
[Music]
my name is marcus my name is cara my
name is connor
[Music]
hey
it's time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so now you know thank you all for
joining us today
and for being part of this amazing
journey
it's your passion as fans of gaming that
drives us to deliver a truly new
generation of experiences on ps5
from everyone at playstation we
appreciate your continued support
and we look forward to you getting your
hands on ps5
very soon to close
let me leave you with one more quick
look
the time was near
you must prepare yourself
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
i feel
[Applause]
[Music]
fearless
uh
so
hey
fearless
well there you have it price and release
date
and possibly one of sony's best press
conferences
if we call if we're still calling him
that ever
in my humble opinion that was
wall-to-wall
bangers i was very afraid for my
colleagues because
oh you guys are gonna die at some point
oh right let's let's kick off we're
talking about price and launch
and then we'll go through all those
games don't worry we're gonna give all
the games they're fair
you other maybe not fortnite okay
so november 12th
in uh america japan 19th rest of the
world
uh we've got 499
for the playstation 5 with the disc
399 without
tam what'd you make of that pricing that
is
obviously microsoft is still coming in a
bit cheaper for the entry level
um however sony had
a they they were in between a rock and a
hard place this entire time with
microsoft pricing and
the manufacturing costs of their own
console obviously we don't have deep
insight into that but
everyone imagined it was going to be
high like people were guessing
super high so the fact that they come in
with these two prices
is is very very very attractive
like i think the the the the price
difference
is from my perspective something that
you make up for
in brand strength like i think that 99
is what people will pay it happily as
the playstation tax like they know what
they're getting
it's like what we're saying that
building that momentum like people have
already got that goodwill
and i think that they have enough
goodwill to pay that little bit extra
if they're interested in making a
decision um between microsoft and
uh sony right now i don't think it's a
competition at all you know
like over here where we're gonna get
both are gonna play both
the most exciting thing we can say is
we've got two consoles
um from each car from each platform
holder four if you're counting each sku
that are incredibly powerful have great
games coming up and are very
very competitively and attractively
priced and
that is just a fantastic thing to get
excited about
michael what about you what do you think
i'm
hey i'm surprised you know i was saying
in the pre-show that i was like you know
sony can get away with charging a little
bit more
uh for their console and uh so i was
like they wouldn't do 600 maybe 550. so
uh 500 for the for the one with the disc
uh that's great i'm surprised by the
diskless one
because four hundred dollars they're
chopping off a hundred dollars
because of a disk drive that's that's
pretty wild
and you know if you look at the series s
that's 300 without a disk drive but it
has a smaller hard drive which you might
want to lean towards getting an
expansion
that that seagate expansion that'll cost
you we don't know how much but it is
going to cost something
um that might make it closer to what the
the diskless ps5
is and it does have it comes with a
slightly bigger
hard drive than what the series s does
so in a way like the diskless version of
the ps5 is kind of
that is aggressive pricing right there
i'm surprised
uh pleasantly surprised of course uh
this is really good across the board for
everyone though like
you don't really have to like if you
have the money
if you were going to buy consoles
regardless um
now you don't have to struggle with like
oh which one like
do i buy the other one because it's
cheaper or more cost effective
it's like well both options are priced
the same and you're getting
a lot of power and you're getting great
games
i mean assuming they're going to be
great games because
i mean we can we can guess that these
are going to be great games but like
going into the next generation it's
pretty approachable i don't want to
speak on anyone's money i don't want to
count anyone's money but
considering what next the history of the
price of entry to next gen
this is wild 400 can get you into the
ps5 300
can get you into the series the xbox
series platform
yes this is good this is cool yeah and
as as
michael said like it is this very very
strange kind of like
uh discount there considering disk
drives cost maybe what like a few
dollars at this point
like to get in i think the important
thing is i think like sony may have had
this smart discussion we were kind of
speculating what kind of discussion they
would need to have
and i think someone in there went let's
cut it because that hundred dollars may
get loads of people in and if they're on
the diskless version they are in our
ecosystem
for life for the life of this console
and what does it take to be in that
ecosystem to recover that money that's
two game purchases that's maybe like a
game purchase and a subscription to
playstation plus
like they'll make that money back fast
so i am glad that sony made the smart
decisions because
let's face it they have made some
bone-headed decisions in the past when
they're uh
ahead when they're ahead in the clear
like uh you know
in a position of strength but i'm glad
to see that we're not on the cycle where
they make a mistake and then recover
from it and make a mistake and then
recover from it they made the smart
decision here so
well played honestly going into this
next generation of consoles is probably
the most excited i feel like i've ever
been
like it's nice to kind of see both sides
coming out swinging for a change
obviously there are setbacks when it
comes to you know xbox losing halo for
this holiday series but they've gathered
so much goodwill they have so much lined
up
that i'm really excited about and
playstation it's exactly the same but
they have just come out of the gate with
all of these exclusives
and let's go through them boys because
that was
one hell of a showcase i feel like it
was specifically geared
to the people on this panel yeah it's
wild
they listen to all everything we said in
the pre-show are like oh we want this we
want to see this
they're like hey we got you
well mass effect unless mass effect is
coming tomorrow
it'll be the week of dreams so michael
gonna come to you first we talked a
little bit about
final fantasy 16 we've seen some of the
leaks
did you anticipate it to go full
i don't you play a lot of 14 do you did
you anticipated to go like
full 14 like it seems to be doing i
well i'm gonna keep it real with y'all i
have a lot of feelings about this
uh mostly good a lot great
uh some concerns but the fact that
so okay like if y'all know me y'all know
how
[ __ ] damn i'm already losing it
you know how much final fantasy 14 means
to me man like
yo so to back it up a little bit
16 is being made by creative business
unit 3
which is led by naoki yoshida who is the
director and producer of final fantasy
xiv
he is the one who led the team to
rebuild
final fantasy xiv a realm reborn
happened
because he led that project with that
team and then of course
heavensward stormblood shadowbringer
shadowbringers is the best expansion
ever in an mmo
this team or being led
by the unit that naoki yoshida's is
backing up has
me very confident behind uh 16
because they have such strong
storytelling chops
and like this so
what we've seen from 16 is very close to
final fantasy 14
heaven's word which was an incredible
story that was that medieval style of
high fantasy
and it very much looks like that
aesthetic
uh and we see we see
all kinds of final fantasy themes come
through in this trailer if the one
once i saw the chocobo i was like yo
done deal
then shiva then there's ifrit phoenix
all these summons and primals
are all coming into the mix fighting a
dragoon
like i that's the moment where i lost i
was like holy crap
because also like the dragoon is also
the the main focus of final fantasy 14
heaven's word
which is that that that expansion that
came out in 2015 that
made final fantasy 14 such an incredible
game uh
that made it do that next jump so
and the music there's there's that that
strong
backing choir with a loud orchestra
behind it
is like across the board this is
really tapping into final fantasy 14
heaven's word and you love to see it
you really do and as soon as there's
like those hints of the crystal prelude
uh
in there and then once once it hits at
the end then it hits you with the
crystal
prelude straight up and i lost it man
like just hearing that
damn just hearing that just hearing the
prelude like brings back so many
memories
of final fantasy and just like having 14
so fresh in my mind being one of the
most powerful experiences
i've ever had in games and then to see
that all that energy all that energy
channeled into the 16 trailer
it's so wild because then i often feel
like okay 14 is an mmo so
maybe it doesn't have the mass appeal
that
maybe i feel like it deserves but all of
that is being channeled into 16 because
it's being led by
a team backed by naoki yoshida and
it has all those vibes it has the the
same style of music
it has the same aesthetics as the the 14
trailers
so like all the incredible cinematic
trailers with final fantasy 14
of course they're those are made to look
you know better than actual the game
actual looks but 16
in action looks like those cinematics
it has that same same art style that
same vibe
uh and then just seeing it in action and
what we know from 15
uh going into seven remake in terms of
combat style because we actually saw
combat there
and i'm just thinking of the
possibilities of how you can integrate
the themes of final fantasy 14 heaven's
word and then
the all the things that had evolved with
the series in
seven remake and it's the the
possibilities are wild man
and yeah it's i'm i'm so excited for
this man
i i i lost i stood up and i was just
like yelling and screaming and
when i looked up like oh creative
business new three that rings a bell and
then
seeing like that's the team that's naoki
yoshida's team
and i s man it's
wild but i will say before before i let
it go
i will say that there are i do have some
concerns about
you know maybe what we've seen so far in
that
you know 14 has a incredible reputation
of having very
like a broad range of complex characters
uh including women
and very like very good women characters
in their games that are integrals of the
story and we kind of saw like that that
that boys road trip kind of thing with
15.
here there's a lot of focus on male
characters as well
of course we don't know where this is
going uh obviously the first time we've
seen final fantasy 16
but i think like some of it's uh the
series strongest stories
lie in its uh women characters and i
want to see
more of where that's going uh i do feel
like the the character designs that we
saw
in this trailer do kind of lean into
some of the things that we've already
seen throughout the series history
uh but again this is the first time
we've seen it there's
probably a lot more that or there is a
lot more we don't know
um but those are just my early takes on
this but overall man i did not expect
to see 16 to this level because i was
just thinking like oh maybe
a title card maybe a 30-second teaser
cinematic
they went full-on showed uh like the the
basis for the story
showed combat and had music and
it was a lot of story set up
and just nailing everything that i love
about final fantasy
uh in particular final fantasy 14 came
through in this trailer
i am so hyped man
yeah i i i just want to point out like
how
this is this was a press conference or
stream of a lot of big brain moves and
for for square enix this is a big brain
move like
if it wasn't clear from mike michael's
tone like final fantasy
14 is pretty phenomenal when it comes to
storytelling i haven't even played all
of it and
i i can see the value in it and i can
see the strength of that
so the fact that they've taken the team
or some of the team that's responsible
for
taking one of his biggest failures in
recent memory and making it the best mmo
on the market now and perhaps of all
time to and using that team
to give some kind of grounding and a
little more strength to their
their main games which have been
floundering in a lot of ways is such a
smart move
not only have they taken that team and
and kind of given a stable
kind of foundation for the mainline
series but they've also diversified that
series
in two ways now they have final fantasy
vii remake which is for their modern
fans who
like that nomura style you know kind of
more uh
steampunk cyber future kind of final
fantasy but now they also have the
classic final fantasy running parallel
to it in a way that's accessible to
people who
only play the main line final fantasy
games and don't dip into the mmo crowd
that's a lot of people
that don't go into final fantasy mmos or
mmos as a whole
now they've got two tracks for final
fantasy that exists side by side
which is so so smart and it's going to
make them so much money if they do it
right
that's unreal like it's really clever
yeah and i think one more thing uh
tam that you mentioned while we were
watching this together is that
this is happening because of final
fantasy 14.
the wild success of 14 is
has at least like i we think this
has had made it possible because of its
wild success and the fact that
it's kind of the the people the brains
behind
making 14 so successful are essentially
put
on 16. this is the fruit of that labor
uh it also makes me think of like what
the next expansion uh for 14 is gonna be
but that's a whole another conversation
i just uh i think there was a
playstation blog post that
uh the next wave of information for 16
is going to come in 2021
uh but in the meantime man you know at
least they let this hype
settle and then we'll get to it in 2021
we'll see where the
where that game is going what a way to
start the press conference as well going
straight from final fantasy 16
into spider-man miles morales they gave
us what we wanted and that was a hefty
chunk of gameplay like
more explanation about what that game
actually
is um i think they must have absolutely
seen the blowback
after the last conference where it was
just basically like oh spider-man miles
morales is a thing
read our blog post to find out more they
had brian horton there
uh from insomniac to actually explain a
little bit more about the game
uh tam like i said you're the comic book
guy
uh out of the three of us what really
grabbed your attention
in this game play i think like the the
first thing that grabbed me was like the
strength of characterization that
immediately
comes through miles i think a lot of
people were wondering what kind of
character miles would be and
i don't think uh there was much worry
about it given how good insomniac
have have been with one character as a
whole and two what they did with peter
um but like the kind of attitude and the
thing that was really striking to me was
this
this short gameplay demo it gave me
chills
in the same way that seeing like a
heroic spider-man moment in a comic
or seeing it in you know spider-verse or
the
the ending of spider-verse the way that
made you feel like
i it kind of captured that here and that
moment at the end where he's holding the
bridge together and pulling
it's that you know it's the cable car
scene from the you know raymie movies
and it's it's every moment from like the
comic book where you
that makes you love uh spider-man and
comics as a whole
and they did it um and the other thing
in terms of gameplay look
looks amazing is the combat it looks
like they've really really update on the
combat
um maybe i'm just misremembering it but
like the fluidity and movement that is
involved here it looks way way more
improved
um the way miles was kind of chaining
cinematic moves together and getting
around the arena but also using his like
unique set of abilities obviously unlike
peter he doesn't have the ability to
like go stealth or manipulate kind of
stack fields or electricity around him
but at times i was i felt like i was
looking at a platinum game which
if you know me or in any of the games i
love like when i see a game and it looks
like a platinum game i am
very very excited about it and like this
looks so
interesting it looks like it's going to
be a satisfying combo system obviously
we won't know until we play it to uh get
our hands on it
but between that the kind of way they're
remixing kind of the universe they've
got the tinkerer in there
and there's some mystery around these
kind of other henchmen type characters
which i feel like is going to feed into
that
i i have a i have a sneaking suspicion
that someone close to miles is going to
it's going to be that proudly situation
from into the spider verse where
you know you find out someone really
close to miles is actually
perhaps there's more to them um so i'm
super super excited about this
uh just checking in on twitter jeff
keely has tweeted that
according to sony plus playstation 5
pre-orders will be live tomorrow so
that's from jeff i'm not sure where he's
getting there from writing that anywhere
but jeff's tweeted out so blame jeff
but allegedly yes my pre-orders out
tomorrow
so it's gonna be a long day of
so allegedly until they announced it
until they took that out themselves but
that's
what's going on on social media right
now let's move on then
to the another worst kept secret in
gaming especially because like a full
gameplay demo
of this leaked a good couple years ago
now i was wondering
when we would get to see harry potter um
hogwarts legacy obviously not the best
time to be talking about harry potter
giving jk rowling
given jk rowling i guess is the uh the
safest way to say that
um i do feel terribly sorry for everyone
who works at the studio and has put
years of work into a game
uh and the creator of the franchise is
just you know
appalling on twitter and imploding
however let's separate the art from the
artist
um and honestly like i got the press cut
the press release from warner brothers
and i was kind of giving it a skim
she is not mentioned in this until like
the very very bottom where it's
basically
this is based on harry potter which was
made by jk rowling that's literally
i'm taking that as in good faith that
she's not very much involved in it
i'm hoping um but anyway hogwarts legacy
leaked a few years ago
we knew it would be taking you back to
the 1800s and you know it's just
the hogwarts rpg game that i think a lot
of us especially those
who grew up with harry potter game the
hype of books
and only games we had were the terrible
but like
oddly charming tie-ins of the movies
um i am really excited for this one like
even though i thought
and obviously you know recent events
have kind of put harry potter like way
far from my mind
i got those chills that i felt like when
i was a teenager and i was getting the
final couple of books
and you know i was just super excited to
be in that world even the music was kind
of stirring something up in me
i like i just love the sound of it it's
like
become the witcher wizard you want to be
like you can decide to
become like really good at potions or
like
care of magical creatures and defense
against the dark arts and all that kind
of stuff
and like seeing different creatures from
the harry potter world
like i feel like did we see azkaban
there like there was that bit with
dementors and a place to look to help
prison there's dragons i'm
i'm really into it but i'm so conflicted
about it and i think
a lot of harry potter fans especially
older ones who are seeing what's going
on with the series creator
um are kind of quite like how to
separate the art from the artist but
harry potter means
so much to so many people and i
like i play this i i want to play this
really badly
like
i would i would encourage people to like
i'm in a similar situation where i
i love those books um and in recent
years have kind of pulled away
in my how exuberantly i expressed my
fandom around them for obvious reasons
but
i would i would recommend if you're
having trouble with that like especially
given
how good this game looks because it
looks like i think sean luke described
it as like
the harry potter game everyone has been
asking and waiting for you know this
full rpg type experience where you get
to be in hogwarts and
and be a a growing budding wizard and
grow up and
you're naturally going to feel excited
about that but also like lucy said
conflicted i would recommend and
encourage people to seek out daniel
radcliffe's response to what jk rowling
has been doing recently because it's a
very thoughtful very smart and very
interesting way to approach it and the
long and short of it if you can't read
it is like don't don't let her destroy
what it mean to you and don't let her
destroy
what it taught you you know that love
can be a powerful
force and it can you know all people are
accepted and that kind of stuff so it's
it's
what it means to you um can't be tainted
by what she's doing now in retrospect
because that growth is there and a part
of you now so
seek that out and read that and then
watch the trailer again because it is
incredibly exciting um
and i don't think a lot of us should
feel awful about
um you know uh being excited about it
yeah i mean god
it really it's one of those things back
i haven't really thought about harry
potter like that in years so
you know like i'm sorry
watching the trailer kind of it uh it
it kind of instilled that same
excitement when we knew that
you know universal was universal studios
that they were going to have
uh area like they were going to have
harry potter in the amusement park and i
when i went there i was like
so bewildered by the fact that i felt
like i was in the movies i feel like
the things i read in the book were came
to life there even though it was just
like
hey i'm go chill on these benches it's
summer in california but i got butter
beer
i'm chilling and also like getting your
own wand and like
just the the way that amusement park
like captured the magic there
that same feeling kind of comes through
when you see this trailer because
like like y'all said it's it's the game
that you always dreamed of like an rpg
where you get to like spend
hours and hours in this world where you
get to grow with it because that's the
thing about rpgs
is that you play a character who grows
throughout this thing there's a lot to
explore
i assume and it's just like
like the harry potter world is is so
rich with that
and to finally have that game nail it
and that one thing i will say about like
a hundred i one thousand a billy wow
agree with y'all on what all y'all said
about jk rowling
um i'm with you on that you all know me
um
what i will say is that i am betting
i'm willing to bet that the writing team
the people who are creating this game
the people who are writing this story
are also fans of harry potter and then
they are kind of i i hope that they are
making it their own
right and that they channel kind of the
fandom that they grew up with
into creating the stories that they
wanted to see in this world that they
you know love like us so uh
with that said i oh boy
i can't wait to see where this goes yeah
me too i mean honestly before we move on
i just want to say
i'm excited for harry potter story
that's not about harry
like yeah like
as certainly as the series went on i
became less attached to him as a
character and fell more in love with the
world and the surrounding characters and
so
i think what's built like those
foundations of this
fully realized wizarding world is like
that's what i want to explore and i want
to do it through my own
eyes rather than oh harry
potter harry potter but anyway let's
move on
i'm going to draw too long on cod blop's
cow
um but michael i will come to you for
this one because you uh out of all of us
who have seen
most of it you've been like uh behind
constore's presentations about the game
sorry i don't know if you can hear my
roommate
very excited about something um well
maybe he just saw the the jeff update
where he says that pre-orders
might be available today allegedly look
jeff has got all this
knowledge
yeah scene um
and can we also just talk about this
incredible homage to the ending of fast
and furious 6 on this runway
uh yeah so uh i mean i won't spend too
much time talking about
black ops cold war because i had
previewed this game twice already
actually
um one for the single-player
presentation which uh we saw
we saw a little bit of this in that
presentation so we got to see this full
cinematic play out uh very bombastic it
you know it uses the cold war as a
foundation to tell
like this wild conspiratorial global
story um i'm interested to see where it
goes because i think black ops does
really interesting things
with its narrative and this game does
have elements of
different mission designs there will be
branching paths at certain points
there's going to be decisions to make
the there's going to be some
as i say quote unquote mind [ __ ]
which uh
they said they've said themselves so i
think i'm fascinated in that regard
i'm not too keen on like it's um how
it's leveraging real world politics into
it
i think that's a very touchy thing to uh
to get with but if you just want
bombastic
uh silly mind-bending action like this
will probably be your jam
um but you know like i was expecting
something a little bit more tempered
honestly
uh but it seems that that's not the case
because they're going like full-on
bombast
with this and you know that can work too
uh but yeah
i think i'm interested to see where this
goes i have some previews of the game
on gamespot.com already from previous
preview events and also i played a ton
of the multiplayer
um so you can go check tho those things
out uh
story breakdowns what what it's doing
apparently ronald reagan is giving you
orders to commit war crimes so
you know the vibes here uh it's try not
to think too hard about it um
until we get to see the full game see
how all that plays out
yeah all right the official playstation
account has tweeted that pre-orders will
be available in some
select retailers starting tomorrow so i
can't believe jeff keeley scooped them
on their own news drop but
pre-orders tomorrow god it's gonna be a
long day of refreshing
uh different various retailers uh let's
move on to resident evil
village um i honestly
i'm excited to see more i think that was
another really good tone piece
for the game i i just i just want it now
i'm kind of also sad that there just
wasn't any news on
for but i guess to be expected tam what
do you think we could possibly see
at uh tgs later this month i think uh
i think a lot of it will be more like
gameplay focus because again like you
said you
you you got like another tone piece out
of it where you know they're showing off
the
the thing that uh capcom has been super
um vocal about uh
vocal vocalizing is um the village
itself is in the title because they want
to treat it as if it's a character
um so they are very much focusing on
showing off like the diverse
like uh environments that are involved
and how it will feel to get around there
but we don't yet have a clear indication
of what it's like to
move from one point to another without
any of the kind of like cutting and
you know uh dramatic camera movements to
kind of accentuate the horror part of it
so i think tgs i'm hoping for a more
clean kind of like here's a five minute
walkthrough of of a
section of the game uh maybe even more
if i loud and also like to see some of
how like the gameplay works
maybe even a puzzle here here or there
too but um the the tone stuff is really
good and it definitely looks like
they're trying more like they had the
you know the kind of like the little
storybook um tale being told
inside the game itself which is
something entirely
new for resident evil it doesn't really
look like this before it looks kind of
like you know a timber entire style
story being told within the resident
evil story which is interesting and cool
and different so at the very least we
know that the team is
going for something different it's
trying stuff and in that little section
it looked like there was gameplay
involved as well like the the
kid running along the branch and that
kind of stuff so i hope that they're
taking more chances they certainly
started doing that with some of the
narrative devices like the videotape in
seven
and kind of like various other time jump
stuff so
yeah um i hope we get to see a little
more clean gameplay and and maybe some
of the weirder things that they're doing
definitely i i'm really looking forward
to this one
and yeah 2021 for resident evil village
uh death loop then another game that we
know has uh has slipped
into next year it's gonna be q2 2021
um michael what did you think of this
new trailer this new look at it
man hey you don't need a there's you
don't need to convince me any further
that
death bloop is going to be a game i want
to play day one and
um you all agree too because y'all are
as hype about
arcane studios work as i am or as any
any
uh these fans of their work are because
man it's you know i said this last time
we we saw death loop
it was like it's combining so many
things that we've seen arcane touch
it has elements of dishonored it has
elements of prey it has
elements of wolfenstein youngblood which
arcane did uh help
make in some ways uh then like lucy when
we were watching i think is you that
mentioned that
you know we're playing a hyper stylized
hitman game too
um it's just it's it's hitting all these
all these tones and it has has so much
momentum at least from
not just like the gameplay standpoint
but in a way it's being presented like
with its
with its uh with its art style and how
that juxtaposes with the world when you
actually play it
there's it's got style with eight
wise and man it looks like a ton of fun
and i think this is one of those games
where level design is going to be key
like how can i how can i use all the
powers and abilities that i have to
navigate
this world to maybe make the cleanest
kill make uh the most
uh like the wildest killed speed running
things like that there's just
it feels like a game that's just meant
for you to figure
out how to do all this wild [ __ ] and be
successful in so many ways
with what the game may ask you and
that's not even touching on like the
intriguing story stuff that's uh that
we've kind of seen already and we got a
little bit more of here
like how is the the concept of like
dying and then being
like re revived and then going again
this this
death loop as you will uh between the
two main characters like how's that
going to
play out there's so many aspects in
which death loop is
an exciting game uh to anticipate and
can't wait to see what the final product
is going to be yeah i have
so much faith in arcane uh a game that i
don't think anyone really expected to
see
uh when capcom's logo popped up again
but devil may cry
5 special edition uh so i've got the
details here ray tracing improved
shadows lighting
4k 30 or 1080 60 optional 120 frames per
second mode
haptic feedback 3d audio and new content
um like tam what do you think about this
one like i
was really not expecting to see this one
did you anticipate it coming to
uh ps5 at launch no i didn't um i guess
i
i i mean capcom has a history of putting
special editions or complete editions of
the devil may cry games out uh
particularly with
you know three is is pretty much special
edition of that game is
pretty well known um and they do like to
follow up with extra content
um and expand their games like they do
that with most devil may cry games
um so i'm not surprised entirely i just
didn't think of it
happening like i just kind of put it out
in my mind so when it popped up i was
like oh initially i was like oh wow
another double mccry game this quickly
um but it turns out it's a new version
of um
five which is yeah i like i'm well up
for that devil may cry 5 plays
incredibly well and you know these are
the types of games that
higher frame rates and better
resolutions just benefit them especially
higher frame rates
like this is a game all about split
second timing precision
combos and that kind of stuff um so just
being able to have those options is
incredibly incredibly valuable um you
know the new content that they talked
about
um i'm sure it's more than just what
they briefly showed off here but um
they they you know virgil looks to be a
little more playable looks like there's
some more i
thought i saw a few more moves and
abilities in there my one
major question is whether they've mixed
up the actual
format of the game in any way because a
large portion of that game you are
spending in one
environment which is quite the same and
luckily the gameplay is so engaging and
engrossing that you kind of are
distracted by it but
knowing that i'm stuck inside that god
damn tree for like hours and hours again
um is definitely gonna be at the front
of my mind but still
like i will always play a game that lets
me to hit buttons
cancel combos and you know hey get that
triple s stylish rank um so i'm excited
especially day one like again
like how can you not how can you be mad
at having a devil may cry game on day
one for the playstation 5.
you can't like it's fair play so the new
content quickly before we move on uh
turbo mode
um fan favorite mode we've got legendary
dark knight difficulty
uh and virgil is playable
all right so like i oh
god there's too many games coming at the
end of this year
for me i think for me to go back to
devil may cry so quickly after five came
out i was only like two years ago
um i don't know it was last year wasn't
it jesus yeah i think yeah
um so i think i may i might leave that
one until early next year but i love the
fact that it's available with new
content all right odd world soul storm
a new trailer and a little a little
introduction from lorne lanning there
uh michael would have come to you what
did you think about trailer like
i just thought again another really
great tone piece
i'm i personally haven't played an odd
world game
since i was a kid but this one has got
me my interest is piqued
what about you yeah i you know
oddworld has oddworld has a special
place for
those who did play it because it's such
a has such a strong mix of
dark you know storytelling and also
just kind of humorous visual styles
uh and kind of narrative uh narrative
beats
but there's there's something really
heavy about
oddworld when you actually like think
hard about it
uh so that has me excited because it's
it's such a unique
uh world and i want to see it again and
also like how they adapt that
classic style of gameplay because it's
not like those um
those early 2000s xbox odd world games
where it's like oh it's
3d now but this is it's kind of like a
2.5 d and i think
you know we've seen since the last time
we've really seen oddworld
make a big push you know we've seen so
many great
2d platformers 2d action games
that have mixed you know or 2.5 d you
know elements of the 3d world in there
as well
so you know i gameplay wise you know if
they can still channel some of that
magic
i'm all for that uh too but narratively
i think
um that's where oddworld strikes with me
and
uh you know it's a little hard to tell
like what it's going for
or how it's gonna hit or land but
something i definitely want to see yes
odd world back is it's a good thing
uh we're getting it like more news is
still trickling in um
so moving on from oddworld very quickly
horizon uh forbidden west is going to be
coming to the ps4
as well um i would have anticipated that
one of the games that they're really
pushing on ps5 but it is nice
that it is gonna be on both uh jen's
we'll talk about the launch lineup in a
second
let's quickly five nights at freddy's
it's a thing that never really i played
the first one didn't
get it personally but i appreciate it
for what it's done like it definitely
hugely contributed to the rise of like
let's plays and stuff on youtube and
has spawned quite just a surprisingly
huge
uh following and you know like this
cult um this cult game i guess
i suppose and so i'm not sure what this
game is going to be on ps5
um five nights at freddy's on ps5 um
also fortnight is coming and also can i
just say that this is
this was around the 40 minute mark and
then the press conference
and when i tell you when i thought they
were ending with fortnite
the things that i saw however that
wasn't the case
um but we did also get demon souls so
that has been confirmed to be
a ps5 launch tile look at him go
look at him
demonstrate i called it i said it i
meant it
i got it let's go
tam from your perspective like while we
were watching it all i could hear was
you going it looks so good
it looks so good what caught your eye um
when we were watching this gameplay that
blue point
the mighty image that they have it is is
honestly the midas touch
like they are a team that has time and
time proven again
that they are capable of making games
look absolutely incredible
without sacrificing or impacting the
essence of what they are
and this trailer was very laser focused
in showing the people who love these
games
that that stuff is intact like i want to
watch it again
and i cuz you know in in special
conditions that i
have set up specifically for watching
souls trailers and from software games
to analyze it but like this looks
absolutely stunning like this is
like this amount of detail wasn't in the
original version of boletaria like you
the
the things that they have gone is not
just like let's just make everything
you know look better and not touch it
any in any other way they have clearly
been given artistic license to look at
and understand what each
area what this game you know kind of
represents and what
from software wanted out of that that
moment that thing that you know level
that sequence and try and enhance that
and that's what this looks like you're
walking through like the early areas
it's not just a one for one shot for
short remake it's like
they understood the spirit of it and the
essence of it and they've done
everything here to make it
you know adhere to that in a way that
gives it new life
whilst also making sure that it is the
game that people remember
know and love and the one thing that i'm
really still like looking at is
it moves differently it looks different
and
i really am excited to see what is
causing that it looks weightier
there's a certain gliding quality that
early from software games have
where you kind of like are almost
sprinting in a way that feels unnatural
and it doesn't feel right that like a
character holding a sword a shield and
wearing
a knight's armor is suddenly able to
like burst into this sprint
but it's what it needed to be to make
the game work
this feels like the weight of what
you're holding the weight of what you're
wearing and the weight of the world
you're in and the things that you
experience
is very much reflected in the way that
you're moving and the way
that you're kind of like traversing
through these environments the character
the way like the footsteps look and
seem to feel um as you're watching them
feel a little more like
well not plotting but like they have a
little more heft to them
and i'm excited to see how that
translates to the way you feel when you
press buttons
demon souls from software games known
for how deliberate they are
so i feel like they they have the
opportunity to make those changes and
perhaps slow it down a bit
and give add that weight to it without
impacting the gameplay
like i said they're always about
deliberate moments choosing your moments
and um blue point now are like at this
point have they been
earned the benefit of the doubt and
we've got the uh first
um look at the the tutorial boss here
which
almost everyone dies to but looking
absolutely stunning
um i'm just like so excited i'm so glad
that it's gonna be their day one
obviously you know how much i care about
from software games and souls games
specifically so
knowing that i can spend money on a
playstation
and then immediately have one of my
favorite games ever
available to me to play not just this
game but one we'll talk about again
later
it's just like it's just a it's just a
an incredible like it's a dream come
true scenario
like that's all you can say about it
everything's coming up tam uh speaking
of long titles they have released uh the
launch
list so we've got astros player room
demon souls destruction all stars marvel
spiderman miles morales
uh sac boy a big adventure and
they seem to have confirmed the 70
price tag um on like next-gen games
which i think everyone
figured was coming i think for me
personally it stings a little less
because the consoles are cheaper
or at least within the price range that
i feel i can
you know live with um but also
i'm interested to see if they're gonna
make changes to ps plus pricing so they
also announced today
within the press conference sony been
doing a very weird thing
uh where they just like leave out a
bunch of key information
and then everyone has to find out from i
don't know like twitter
it's very strange when you're having a
showcase you should probably have all
the
information in there that's just a note
for them for next time
not bitter but it's very strange to me
playstation
collection is being added as a part of
playstation plus so
that means games like god of war monster
hunter final fantasy xv
fall out uh fall up i think it was four
days gone uncharted like all the big
beefy playstation games uh as well as
some third-party titles such as
battlefield 1
arkham knight uh persona 5 but it didn't
look like
royal um resident evil 7
and tam let's go
let's go at launch
we're going to have demon souls and
bloodborne
let's go what a time to be alive
what a time to be alive ah that's all i
could ask for i am so
glad that i will be able to play
bloodborne my my ongoing obsession
will be fueled by sony i'm really
interested to see what kind of
um kind of improvements are going to be
made to the game it doesn't look like
they've mentioned any specific things
about you know we've changed the frame
rate or anything like that
but you've got to imagine that it's
going to be improved in some to some
degree just by the virtue of the
playstation 5 being more powerful
i i mean like even if it's just simply
the original game is available to me in
the way it always played
on the new console that's good enough
man i i'm always playing that game so
knowing that i don't have to keep my
playstation 4 hooked up for this one
game
is massively helpful and with any luck
more people will blablab play bloblom
because you know everyone should be
playing it so
i'm happy i am very happy what a day and
then
uh the final the the real mic drop i
think moment for me the just one more
thing
uh was god of war the sequel um i'm not
gonna spoil the ending of 2018's god of
war
but if you played through sat through
the credits there was
a big hint about what was to come uh
featuring a specific character
um but yeah god of war i'm not sure what
even what it's called i'm just going to
call it god of war 2 at this point
uh ragnarok is coming like michael you
said that
you know if final fantasy 16 was just
the logo
you'd be hyped we got that treatment
with god of war
how are you feeling about it uh i'm a
little surprised by i guess how soon
uh just because you know god of war was
2018 uh it's still
pretty fresh in my mind and uh yeah
coming out like hey sony santa monica
they're hitting 2021
or that's what they're saying is like oh
okay like they've been on the ball with
that and
it's the 2018 god of war was a rebirth
of the series too that
uh you know took it in a different
direction you know if you're into dad's
stories
one of the greatest dad stories that you
can have in games
personally not my necessarily my uh the
the thing i necessarily get hyped about
but i i got mad respect for what they
were able to do
uh with the god of war franchise and
rejuvenated and so now it's on
its brand new trajectory with uh like
this and
having it pretty soon because i i think
of these big franchises have at least
you know
four years uh uh for a cycle like
i don't know just cause like these games
are so big and so detailed uh but they
have such a strong foundation to work
off of
and like you said you know the the end
of 2018's god of war
you know i made it made it pretty clear
that you know there's there's going to
be more so
uh yeah this is man like
so the give giving the just the title
card to let you know that it is it is
happening for sure
uh like it's we all know that there was
going to be another god for it was just
a matter of when
and uh just getting that confirmation
that it is
on the horizon it is 2021 is you know
not that far off so it's just be hitting
hitting spider-man
hitting like who knows when final
fantasy's gonna come but we'll know more
um hitting with god of war just like all
these marquee franchises that
playstation
can really leverage to be like this is
the reason why you should be on this
platform these exclusives
not just in the near future but yo we
got we got our things sorted out
for the future and god of war is like
one of those games that can just like
that everyone knows that can just be
like oh playstation
if i get a ps5 that is on the horizon
for me and
horizon is on the horizon as well so
man that's that's strong man like this
this isn't about a lot of this
conference wasn't about the launch of
the ps5 it was like
yes we're launching at these prices you
can have these games but look at all the
stuff that you can get into
a year down the line next year when
we've had
people when we have people with ps5s
these are all the things that you can be
excited about
so strong yeah all right uh
that was a truly incredible press
conference i think
i'm i'm just very excited about where
gaming is going i like whether that's
sony or whether that's with microsoft
like
i think some of the titles that we've
got to be looking forward to
look fantastic and so time i'm going to
come to you what are your final thoughts
on
today's showing from sony i think that
was a fantastic
uh press conference and like you said
like just an incredible time
to be interested in video games between
microsoft having
a incredibly cheap and powerful console
two skus of those cheap and powerful
consoles
and then game pass and just like giving
access
access to so many people so easily to
the console
just amazing if you are interested in
microsoft and if you're on the
playstation
you know looking at playstation you've
got again powerful consoles
very competitively priced and so many
big classics like
for regardless of where you go whether
it's one the other or both
you are gonna get your money's worth to
start with at the very least for me
personally
like demon souls they're at launch
bloodborne they're at launch spider-man
they're at launch a god of war on the
way
like that is just a phenomenal showing
from sony like we are
we have been stuck in these goddamn
houses for many many many months at this
point and
we can't even pretend like it's fine but
for a minute there i felt like i was at
e3 and
that is saying a lot about the the kind
of impact that
that that press conference had so well
played sony like fair play
michael what are your closing thoughts
on the conference today
uh agree with all things tam said uh
pricing surprised me that's really good
uh but man you know final fantasy 16
like i had to step
out for a minute um damn if there's just
one thing that could have just won me
over
immediately it was that and i
just in case i i don't want to spread
like misinformation or anything but
like naoki yoshida is producer on the
game not director
uh so he is supervising that but that
still does give me a lot of the
confidence to bring the storytelling
chops
and just like the the rich deep
narratives that they've known for
they he's been known to supervise with
14.
i have confidence that's going to show
through in that game so i mean that
stole the show for me
and like everything else is so it was
wildly impressive but i can't stop
thinking about
final fantasy 16 and just
the connections between that and my
favorite game of all time final fantasy
14 so
um yeah that's you know when people
anticipate conferences they want to see
their game they want to see
that one thing that that's gonna win
them over that's like a console seller
or
you know anything like that they hit it
straight up
and did not stop and i feel like anyone
who is interested in games or
playstation games in general
then there's something to be excited
about you like you can't say that that
wasn't fire
like that that conference was straight
fire and it really did feel like a big
e3 showing
uh and i you know i'm happy
yeah me too it felt a lot like e3 2015
you know the e3 of dreams when it comes
to sony's press conference and like
yeah i had chills the whole time i'm
very excited um so that does about that
all about
does it for us today uh here on the sony
event
post show make sure to stick around
youtube.com gamespot on friday we're
gonna have another episode
of generation next on our weekly show
all about the next gen consoles
and it's gonna be pretty heavy heavily
focused on sony as i'm sure you can
imagine
thank you for joining us today we'll see
you around
peace bye
you